j'ai adoré votre podcast et j'adore
votre livre j'essaie de convaincre mon
frère de lire mais ça l'intéresse pas le
temps d'apprendre à lire de lire
tu fais quoi j'utilise les mathématiques
pour étudier les relations amoureuses
vraiment vraiment
dans la rencontre amoureuse je crois que
je vais t'embrasser c'est
l'improbabilité de rencontrer quelqu'un
jamais vécu un truc comme ça qui fait la
saveur de la rencontre
pour moi explication vous êtes un choc
post-traumatique amoureux non mais
arrête s'il te plaît ne me regarde pas à
chaque fois car tu repasses la porte on
va faire un peu de cas scientifique toi
et moi tu pourrais être notre
mathématicien d'amour si tu le dis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]